Ryoko-chan, actually, I just saw it myself.
Yurairaku is buying parts in bulk, or a super-discount sale of 106 yen per bag.
Did you know
that the eggs you prepared were different from the high-end silky chicken eggs or
branded eggs
?  Or
0 cap ping pyeon
[music]
Another rod type so far
Let's talk about the taste of shiny hair
Ah ah ah
[Applause]
Yes.
By freezing chicken eggs, the protein hardens and becomes jelly-
like, and when it does, it has a springy, creamy texture.
In other words, freezing the eggs is the
key to the
sweetness of this tendon.
There's no way this won't go well with eggs and rice, but if you
use high-quality eggs that are too black, how will the whole thing go bad?
In order
to make the most of both, the egg bones are the best, and
I chose the bargain-sale eggs.
Don't you think it's a perfect item to put a button on?